hello everyone how's everybody doing I
hope you're doing fine here we are
another day another night for me I don't
know if it's stay over there there we
have a good day hopefully and first I
want to remind people we have a
conference in Lusaka Zambia okay and
that's gonna be at the end of the month
we're about a month away from this guy
so you're gonna go get your tickets your
bags ready all that stuff right I'm
gonna have a good time over there gonna
drink some Zambian beer or try it out so
y'all good it is when I remind also
people that we've uploaded a book it's
the rope hypothesis and this book brings
you up to speed on the rope model
specifically what we're doing here with
this book is explaining all the
invisible phenomena okay we're
explaining light certain behaviors of
light the most common behaviors of light
we're explaining gravity electricity
magnetism and the workings of the atom
okay and you can find it at that site
rope hypothesis calm you just go to book
but books there and you'll you'll find a
link to download the PDF file okay those
who wish to translate it again I want to
remind people that you're welcome to
contact us at toca caca at hotmail.com
and let us know if you have a second
language so you want to translate it we
have already a couple people doing that
for a couple languages and I'm
translating into Spanish hopefully I'll
finish one that's sometime this year now
I should be assumed that I put it online
okay anyways so what's the day about
well today I want to continue where I
left off the other day okay and that was
light and now you get to finish the
whole story and I want to fill in the
blanks make sure
[Music]
we get the proper message across of you
know what I was trying to say last week
to make points okay so let's go with
that let's start there you got this so
big hold it
let's get that down the size yeah and
this is what I was trying to say the
other day you know there's that's fine
yeah the main points were that
mathematics mathematicians the people
who run the world they clean they make
the following claims they say that when
light passes from a lighter to a denser
medium you know one that is rare one
that has less density and goes to a
denser medium like from air to glass
that's the typical example they say that
light slows down light travels at a
different speed dang that's the official
version to calculate the speed of light
through the denser medium the
mathematicians invented an artificial
parameter known as refractive index I've
used refractive index for many years
because we use it in the semiconductor
industry every day so we used 145 for
glass the typical value out there is 1.5
it's better to deal 1.5 because it gives
you almost a perfect 200,000 kilometres
per second
further for light going through glass
the questions whether that's real
whether that's what actually happens
when light goes through glass from air
to glass does that happen does light
slow down okay and the alchemists
explain that wavelength shortens the
wavelength becomes shorter okay and
frequency is unaffected frequency
remains the same what changes only the
wavelength and because the wavelength
shortens right
the speed of light shortens that's the
official version okay and gullible
individuals who follow the math
magicians and don't know any better you
know they
extrapolate that since color is a
function of frequency
remember frequency doesn't change right
wavelength gonna change the color of
light does not change as it passes
through the denser medium okay I hope
that's understood
you're saying that light goes from air
to glass okay glass is a denser medium
than air
there's a gas right this is micarta
supercooled liquid they've got all types
of names it's a solid for sure yeah
because you touch glass and it's kind of
hard right and they say when he goes
from the less dense to the denser medium
what changes is only the wavelength and
so these people will say well since
color is a function of frequency and not
of wavelength then wavelength then color
does not change when it goes through the
denser medium that's that's the this is
the worldly wisdom today okay so I hope
that's clear as what we tried to say the
other day okay what's wrong with all
this okay let's go with the first one
this is what they're saying okay they're
saying that light comes in there okay
into a glass it comes from here which is
the bluish part on the outside goes
through glass okay and it goes slower
they claim they claim that it goes
through slower through glass about two
thirds folks slower it goes three
hundred thousand kilometers per second
in the blue part and then when it goes
into this whitish area it goes at two
hundred thousand kilometers per second
why because the electric field slows it
down
it mingles the electric field mingles
with the light the field of the or or
the electric and magnetic fields of the
of light and it slows it down okay so
how did they ever determine this okay
they did it mathematically okay that's
that's how they did it and this this is
this is the official version here you
have two
representations to statements made by
people at the Stack Exchange which I've
mentioned the other day and the third
one comes from the Wikipedia okay and
they all say the same thing I just want
to make establish that this is the
official version okay just so you know
okay when a beam of light crosses the
boundary between two mediums its
frequency does not change its wavelength
changes okay so it is not an
experimental fact now we're talking
about facts this is proven and you got
to take it to the bank okay that
refraction does not affect color
so they're saying two things here not
only does the wavelength change but
color does not change because frequency
doesn't change and a claim that color is
a function of frequency okay so one can
conclude that color is frequency
dependent another file says the
frequency of a light wave does not
change from medium to medium while the
speed of light and thus wavelength does
okay I think I hope it's clear okay by
knowing the frequency of an
electromagnetic wave you know its color
in other words since since frequency
doesn't change and color is not going to
change right in any medium the color of
an electromagnetic wave is defined by
its frequency so they claim that
frequency does not change when it goes
to the denser medium because I mean
color doesn't change because frequency
doesn't change but change is only the
speed of light because wavelength
changes shortens okay and then Wikipedia
confirms all this the refractive index
can be seen as the factor by which the
speed and the wavelength of the
radiation are reduced with respect to
their vacuum values in other words if
you compare glass or any other material
but glass is a good example
glass versus vacuum which we find out
there in space well they claim that you
know light travels slower glass okay
what's the reason says the speed and the
wavelength of the Riddhi radiation
wavelength right are reduced with
respect to their vacuum values the
frequency
of the wave is not affected by the
refractive index okay
frequency doesn't change remains
constant because color is a function of
frequency according to these
representations color doesn't change
when it goes through a denser medium the
only thing that changes is the
wavelength which means that what's going
to change is the velocity of light and
so we got to find out where this all
comes from and here you see the equation
today you don't need to be an expert in
physics or math to understand this
velocity of light we will see 300,000
kilometers per second is equal to
wavelength which is that lambda times
frequency the little left there okay
that's the equation it's a constant
little C but they claim it's a constant
only in the vacuum okay only in the back
okay so keep that in mind so in the
vacuum we have 300,000 kilometers per
second and I gave an example here this
is just an example we have the color red
650 nanometers that essentially is a
color red that's the wavelength 650
nanometers is the wavelength what's the
frequency 4.6 terahertz okay okay so
that's in the vacuum what happens when
it hits SiO 2 glass okay well the
refractive index is 1.5 that means
you're gonna divide 300,000 kilometers
per second by 1.5 that gives you 200,000
kilometers per second that's how they
get that number okay what change did the
frequency change
no it's still 4.6 thirds and what you
what does change is the wavelength
that's that's what they're claiming okay
so I hope you understand that much
wavelength changes in fact it shrinks it
shortens and because it shortens light
travels at a slower speed frequency
remains the same and since color is a
function of frequency they claim that
color does not change either they claim
that to have proven it experimentally
okay that's that's that's the official
version okay let's find out what's wrong
with all this yeah here it is first so
you can visualize what they're saying
okay you can see the waves of light
coming into the glass that blue part is
glass
okay the waves of light electromagnetic
waves because they have to do with waves
they can't do with particles right they
have these waves come in and they
flatten out in the direction of travel
because what they're saying is the wave
length shortens but you can see the weak
frequency remains the same that I put
three lines there to show you that the
same number of waves pass through that
given point and the same so frequency
doesn't change what's changing is only
the flattening out in the direction of
travel of the wave length okay and and
so yeah this is this is where we have
this this is what they're proposing
guide and we have a couple problems the
first one is this the spectrum okay the
spectrum the color spectrum okay
is always given in terms of wavelength
it's not given hardly ever in terms of
frequency some people put it in terms of
frequency as well like that first one
but the second one is the more common
you'll see it only under wavelength
wavelength in other words color changes
with wavelength so if you change the way
then you change the color these people
are saying that when light goes through
a denser medium and it flattens out in
other words the wavelength shortens
because light shows they claim that
light doesn't change
well that violates the visible spectrum
not to mention the entire spectrum but
also the visible spectrum under the road
not very easy you know it's piece of
cake no problem C equals lambda times
frequency is the equation of a rope it
can only be modeled by a rope okay well
I don't know maybe someone smart me can
find something else that miles it but
here you have it you have how many links
there if you count the blue one you have
four links okay
more or less and if we undercut okay now
you have what two links and each link is
longer so you have fewer links frequency
okay and greater wavelength okay the
wavelength is longer now if you target
one more time right
for the same amount of rope I haven't
changed a rope this is it this is the
whole thing okay
now I have shorter links and each and
you have more links okay so now you see
why velocity of light never changes
anywhere in the universe no matter what
material it goes through because the
theory that we're proposing is that the
rope binds any two atoms and so the only
thing they can do is torque in on torque
they didn't have longer link lengths and
fewer links or more link more links and
shorter link links that's it and that's
what you see at the bottom there
that's the spectrum according to the
Rope model you can see it fits perfectly
there we have no problem with it we
don't have to shorten the wavelength and
keep frequency the same okay that's the
point that I'm trying to make and the
other point that I want to make is that
color is a function of wavelength which
these people are saying it's not so it
contradicts the spectrum and the
spectrum has been I mean you can you can
look it up on your own you'll find it
everywhere so they have to explain why
if wavelength changing why doesn't color
change if color is a function of
wavelength so this is the first problem
that deal the they have a contradiction
they have to resolve that contradiction
okay that's the first issue okay what's
the second issue well the second issue
is why does the wave go slower and these
people are saying okay the reason it
goes slower is that the wavelength the
wave of light which is the first one
they're the one that's coming into the
glass right hits the hits the electrons
of the atoms that comprise the glass and
what happens is the electrons now start
waving as well and they mixed you have
the wavelength of light mixed with a
wavelength or the waves of electrons and
they slowed down okay and the problem
here is that first there is no such
thing as a wave in science
wave is a verb not a noun okay there's
no such standalone object called wave
and that's the first thing that destroys
their whole argument but then assuming
we concede the wave what is the
mechanism why does the in other words
why does the electron wave slowed down
the light way the waves of light you
know we have no reason we have no
mechanism all they say is it is sub when
that's it
so this is the problem and the other
issue here is that you know when when
the waves go back to air well Arius is
full of all kinds of you know particles
as well I mean what is air
art error is an air a bunch of atoms a
bunch of molecules and if it's a bunch
of air if air is a bunch of atoms and
molecules what's different about them
from the others from from the electrons
that form the glass well what is the
difference in other words why doesn't I
mean you're gonna look at a big
difference here you're saying you're
saying that in the case of air light
travels through almost 300,000
kilometers per second travels almost
according to them accordion and it
travels almost at the same speed as
through the vacuum and through glass it
goes much slower those are two hundred
thousand okay that's the problem and
you're saying well what's different
about the medium I mean between these
two between air and glass I mean
air is also made out of electrons and
atoms and molecules so they would have
to explain what the difference is and
they don't do it they just say it is so
so so we have a problem in that we don't
have an explanation a mechanism of why
light slows down and you'll never have
it with the word wave because wave is
not a physical object you cannot use the
word wave as a physical object which is
what they're doing here they're saying
there is something called a wave and
this wave class is against another way
that's like saying love clashes against
intelligence and it slows it down what
have you learned you know
you have two concepts that's all you
have is concepts these people are
juggling concepts and saying oh we have
one concept hit another concept that's
all they said okay we don't have objects
and hopefully air is a physical objects
made out of atoms okay it better be
something physical and glasses also made
out of physical so you have to explain
this in physical terms you have to
illustrate it and not say wave and wave
what what's waving that's what you gotta
identify otherwise you have no mechanism
and that's where the problem is okay so
what is our model well very simple you
can see straight forward none of that
nonsense the rope is connected to an
atom and here we only show one atom okay
and the atom pumps back and forth doing
its quantum jump by doing so it torques
the rope and now you can see why it goes
slower through glass than through air
because what we have here is that the
atoms are you know crystal lattice and
so they don't pump as hard as they do in
air and so the wavelength is what
changes but now we have a mechanism
because we can say look what we've
traded here is link length for the
number of links that's what we did so
now you can visualize why light slows
down you can't do that with a wave I
mean what's the problem with having the
wave increase both frequency and
wavelength and travel faster than light
there's no impediment no mathematically
you can do it but physically what's the
physical cause and here you can see the
physical cause you cannot trade
wavelength for frequency other than like
what happens in a rope either you have
more links and each link is shorter or
you have longer links and you have fewer
what is called as frequency K and you
can see that the fits the equation
perfectly the wave equation C equals
frequency times waiting for that one
goes up the other one goes down period
we're done so it's straightforward none
of this nonsense about waves and up
magical interference between two waves
whatever those are you know no
explanation no mechanism you're as blind
as you came in you know you don't learn
anything with these people because they
don't have a mechanism they just say it
is so and again they hold frequency
constant artificially and they say well
like go slower and that's it take it or
leave it
yes that's the way it is yeah the thing
I wanted to address the the other day is
this fellow our Nomura and what he did
he says here and he claims to have
manipulated one electron at a time he
said these spots indicate individual
electrons doing a slit experiment right
electrons are detected one by one you
can be confident that they are l that
electrons are particles okay and then of
course he reaches a crazy conclusion
says what accumulated interference
fringes are formed and we have reached a
conclusion which is far from what our
common sense tells us no kidding and the
reason is because he's doing this with
bullets okay so what is Tana more and
I'm doing well he's he thinks he's in
the he steam thinks he's in a shooting
range if he'd give me a second here and
you'll see it come up and he thinks he's
shooting bullets okay and that's what
he's that's how he's gonna make his
friends this with bullets yeah he just
shoots a bunch of bullets she claims to
have handled one bullet at a time okay
and that's how he makes his interference
fringes yes yet here that's what he
claims is doing and he says well you can
see that it's obviously their bullets I
mean what other conclusion can you reach
what other possibility is there but let
me enlighten mr. Tamura
okay here's another possibility okay for
you to consider yeah how about drilling
we drilled the holes okay is that a
possibility that we just drilled them
okay we drill holes and here you'll see
him are those bullets one of those
drilled PE Tony so maybe he drilled
those holes into the wall has he ever
thought about that
possibility that there's another
mechanism that does not involve bullets
so this is the issue these people are
doing with bullets for the last 400
years more I mean even even in the days
of the Greeks they were only talking
about bullets the only time they
introduced the way was when Robert
hooked in the 17th century wrote his
book micrographia I think it was what
1665 I think it was and and he talked
about the ways light being made of ways
then
christiaan huygens you know a few years
later you got a hold of that idea and he
started playing around you know with
waves of water and try to try to explain
light in terms of water waves you know
and he got into a little struggle there
with Newton who said no no no light is
made of particles they they all said
particles because they all vouch for the
ether both Newton and everyone in the
17th century dealt with the ether what's
these are a bunch of particles that's
what the ether is and Newton said you
know light travels through the ether and
the other guy said no it's neither
that's vibrating up and down and that's
that's where they ran into trouble okay
they you know a little clash of
philosophy there and to this day no one
has fix that problem okay so what is the
problem with Tana Morris version of
bullets being shot at the target well
here you have a chamber okay and we have
electrons according to the official
version we have electrons flowing from
one atom to another and this is what the
mathematicians call electric current or
electricity they say it's the flow of
electron beads they call charges which
is another concept but they they're
thinking of balls they're thinking of
this little tiny ball which has no
dimensions in no size it's got no volume
it's called an electron this nothingness
goes from atom to atom for whatever
reason they have no idea why it goes
there it just says well when you put a
potential it just does it when you when
you put it within a voltage these little
balls flow
okay let's assume that's true what
happens if we remove the atoms from the
chamber okay we remove more atom can you
flow all the electrons across that
divide can you can you just shoot
electron bullets like mr. Tamura claims
that he's done okay that's the question
can he do that can can we remove more
and more Matta can we pumped the matter
out of the chamber right we pump it down
as electricity is flowing will current
stop flowing at some point without doing
anything else we just have we just have
a current flowing at whatever you know
we have two plates there we have current
flowing from one plate to another and we
pumped down the team but gradually as
much as we can hopefully if we can take
it to minus twelve Torr level would be
great what current start/stop with wood
current stop or continue flowing that's
the question and even before that even
before that mr. Tanimura has a serious
problem and a serious problem is this
one okay this is where the problem is
with quantum mechanics we need to know
what keeps the electron bound to the
proton before he sets the electron in
motion before he ioses
before he turns it into a little bead
that's gonna be part of electricity we
need to make sure that electron is first
attached to the proton somehow and we're
I'm using the hydrogen atom obviously
because it's the simplest to understand
I mean we need to know what's in that
brown region in the center between the
electron and the proton
what is that region what's holding the
electron there to begin with what are
they going to use a concept are they
gonna put an elastic band are they gonna
push the electron by particles from the
outside towards the proton how are we
gonna do this and this is where Tana
Mora has to start he says he handled one
electron at a time before he can handle
an electron he's got to show me you know
what an atom looks like and you have
more bozos here's a group of bozos from
Sweden we have these two bozos and they
claim to have filmed an electron okay so
they filmed an electron I hope mrs. Ann
and mr. Joe had
and can draw an atom for me before they
can tell me that that's an electron that
they film there what did they film I
mean if that's an electron we got a
problem first because the official
version is that an electron is a point
particle it has no volume
no size no no it's a nothing that's what
it is it's a point part of it they don't
know the size of the electron these
people claim to have filmed it in
measure me okay fine let's let's concede
that what does their atom look like I
mean if they can film in the electron
I'm sure they can they can tell me when
an atom looks like and if they can tell
me what an atom looks like is does it
look like the planetary atom that mr.
Gore okay and mr. Rutherford came up
with at the beginning of the 20th
century 1911 1919 they built this atom
this planetary atom what holds the
electron to the nucleus that's all we
need to know and if they can't answer
that question they can't even start
their presentation because they don't
have an assumption they don't have a an
object to begin with so they can't just
continue to the other like to their
theory about electricity and said well
ionization is this and electricity is
that if they cannot tell me how the
electron maintained to remain faithful
to the proton to begin with it's all
they need to do throughout their atom
that's how simple it is it's very easy
and if they filming photographed and
interviewed a an electron bead well they
should be able to give me an atom right
just draw it for me
I mean how difficult can it be we got a
big ball a ball ting bomb called the
proton we have a little B called the
electron I think I could draw that I
mean it's up to them I don't want to put
words in their mouths you know yeah they
need to draw and know like a a an atom
if they can't draw an atom if they
continue with their planetary atom and
then you say well we use the planetary
atom to explain electricity we got a
problem no we got to take one step back
and find out what an atom looks like
before they move the bead okay
that's the issue
and so yeah this is this is what mr.
Tana Mora says he did he says we have
this planetary atom and the question is
what keeps that electron be tied to the
proton that's the only thing he's got
answer what's between the electron and
the nucleus okay because that's the
whole problem that's the whole problem
again that's why they can't make sense
of any of it because they cannot explain
this they cannot explain other words
through magic yay
what binds the electron to the nucleus
that's that's where quantum mechanics
dies right there Indiana they have no
picture of the atom they have pictures
of everything else they have pictures
like I showed the other day I have
pictures of the gluon they have pictures
of the quarks they have pictures of the
electron but they don't have a single
picture of the hydrogen n no can draw on
a hydrogen atom for me in fact I had a
debate a few years back one of my videos
one of my first videos shows you know I
contacted these guys from the
universities professors and so on not
one could draw an atom they say well you
know we don't know what an atom looks
like you know what an electron look a
you know what a gluon looks like you
know what a quark looks it looks like
but you don't know what an atom which is
the big house you know you don't know
what that looks like nonsense they never
they never photograph day they D make
outrageous claims that's what they do
and and a lot of people are gullible and
they swallow all this you know like
candies okay but today I'm gonna talk
about something else I'm gonna do a
seance so right now we need total quiet
because we're gonna be invoking spirits
right now okay we start what we start
with the golden rule the golden
principle of physics you can't do
physics without an object if there's
nothing in the universe there's nothing
going on there's no motion there's no
nothing if you want to do physics you
got to start with objects you got to
have something there that means all the
mediators of gravity of light of
magnetism electricity they had all be
they had all better be mediated by
objects you cannot use concepts to
mediate two physical objects you cannot
say that love pulls a horse to the cart
no no you might pull have the horse pull
on the cart you got to put some pieces
of wood tied to the horse then we can
all understand the mechanism but if you
say look the horse is over there the
cart is over there and when the horse
moves the cart moves what's in between I
don't know a force energy perhaps mass
time no you have to put a physical
object that then we can understand the
mechanism you're gonna put a concept
you're not doing physic you're doing
religion we need to explain mechanisms
people don't understand what that means
so yeah this requires an object the
first thing that a physicist must do is
define the word object the word object
is absolutely indispensable in physics
you need to know what an object is we
define is that which has shape and but I
said the other day is that you know
anyone who really wants to challenge the
Rope model has to start there they have
to start at object they have to define
the word object so far no one has done
so they have to do it in that format
object : and a few words after that
defining what an object is just like I
did here okay just like I did here see
see how you see I'm straightforward that
is no hidden thing I'm not gonna explain
it to you now no there's the definition
object equal guy or : that which has
shape straightforward
now you can challenge it you may not
like it fine but you got a definition I
need a definition from whoever
challenges the Rope model first that's
where they should start and of course
everybody wants a challenge but no one
wants to define and then we have a
problem because the problem is that
people people don't know what an object
is
no one has defined a word in the last
10,000 years and second no one has
defined a second the important word
which is the word exists everybody talks
about what's real what exists and nobody
defines what real and exists mean what
that word me
it's what those two words mean okay
they're synonyms but that's why I said
word okay one guy gave it a shot okay
here is how it just goes quickly through
this he said you said it's not true that
philosophers of philosophers have never
defined object they have oh okay
only what you call object they call B is
that what it was I must have missed it
substance real entity okay mentioned
someone you you may disagree with their
definition but they have them now they
don't that's not a definition okay let
me tell you why being is not a
definition because when you look it up
you find this okay
you look up being and it's just the fact
of existing existence something that
exists so in other words they're saying
that and this fellow saying that or the
Philosopher's are saying that being an
object are the same and if being is
exist then he's saying that existence is
the same thing as an object okay that's
what they're saying well what's the
problem with that well let's look at
vary exist let's see what exists means
well you look it up it says to have
actual B so being and exist are synonyms
we have no definition as of this moment
philosophy if you go into the dictionary
it'll give you definitions applicable to
philosophy says actuality what is that
quality existence reality what is
existence
well again you get back to the same
synonyms that's all you do you go to run
around in circle wikipedia the material
in material existence that's what being
is you look up another place that exists
is I think it's part of the Wikipedia
I'm not sure now existence is the
ability of an entity to interact with
physical or mental reality
I thought reality was a synonym of
existence and then they continued in
philosophy reverse to the ontological
property of being so all we have a
synonym we have existence is reality
reality is being being as existence and
all the actuality we don't have a
definition all we have a synonyms and so
we don't have a definition of being and
so we don't know what a being is and you
can't say that object is being because
they
have a definition being we're done okay
until you get a definition of being
exist actuality reality whatever you
want to call it we don't have a
definition and for sure we are already
pointed out that him and David Hume and
Immanuel Kant Kant could not tell the
difference between re existence and
object and that's the same problem we
have with being they can't tell the
difference and again an object does does
a square exist well the answer is no it
doesn't exist Superman does not exist so
there are objects that don't exist and
they don't have being okay so no you
can't use the word being to define the
word object sorry okay and it gets
because it's irrational not because I
say so
and when you look at the stanford
encyclopedia for object you find this
yeah i mean you can look it up it's so
funny because the philosophers are
so-called philosophers you know these
these morons who work at stanford you
know the the whole encyclopedia is just
garbage every article that i've read so
far has nothing in it and when you do
the object you find this you find all
this discussion on all these
possibilities it just blows your mind
away these guys have been going around
in circles for the last ten thousand
years of talking about nonsense
ontological about existence you know and
and over time find out what an object is
and then they add talk about what
objects do what objects are you know you
should it's it's really better than
stand-up comedy if you go there you'll
see what i mean it's just absolutely
ridiculous okay and so yeah in in in
physics we have to define the word
object and what we cannot use in physics
to move things around our concepts and
here are the most famous concepts okay
we cannot use these words in science
these are words of religion only anyone
using any of these words to try to
explain or terms to try to explain a
phenomenon of physics a mekin
is doing religion any of those words
that you use okay because none of those
are physical objects all of them are
concepts okay this is where it starts
okay okay I'm working with our sands now
okay very quiet okay you had the
introduction there okay here let's go
with it
okay this is what we got to explain okay
we have a situation okay I want you to
explain the mechanism that's that's the
that's how you get the beer you can
explain the mechanism okay otherwise you
don't get the beer
you lose of you you got to pay me the
beer okay it's the other way around so
we're betting a beer here okay who gets
it okay and here it is this is the
situation you have an astronaut and he
falls to earth okay we have to explain
this phenomenon we call gravity okay
call it whatever we want no problem we
can call it X also if you want but let's
call it gravity so that we're all more
or less on the same page now we get
explaining now we have a group of people
here all holding hands around the round
table okay and one of them is Catholic
dang he's a Catholic and he says I can
explain it okay what's the explanation
and he says look an angel is pushing the
astronaut towards birth that's that's
the mechanism you don't see the angel
because you can't touch an angel you
can't see an angel the angel is pushing
the astronaut to earth and he goes there
and he illustrates it for us okay so now
we see that there's an angel and he's
really pushing the astronaut towards the
Earth okay we can all understand that
okay but the Atheist comes in and says
ah but I don't believe in angels and
angels not a an object an angel is a
concept and so you haven't explained the
mechanism
well the Atheist would be wrong on all
counts he's simply wrong he doesn't
understand the mechanism under stand the
scientific method that's why he said
such dumb thing first of all an Angels
an object it's not a concept
okay and and this comes to the issue of
people not defining terms what is an
object it's that which has shape did you
just see a shape there carrying the
astronaut though don't you see something
with wings here or do you only see an
astronaut because if you only see an
asteroid you got a problem with your
eyes you got to go see an
ophthalmologist okay
there's something there we call it an
angel that angels carrying the astronaut
to earth so not only is an angel an
object but the mechanism is clear the
angel is pushing the astronaut to earth
so what is it that the Atheist doesn't
understand we have every element that we
need we have an object called an angel
and this angel is pushing me astronaut
to earth we understand the mechanism now
the person says why I don't believe in
angels that's a different story yet now
you change the subject see the guy the
the the conference is about mechanisms
and he religious individual is saying
look I believe in angels it doesn't
matter if he does or not but he says let
us assume there are angels okay
the angels are untouchable unseeable
okay but they have shape obviously
because he made it visible for us he
made the angel visible so that we could
see the mechanism not that we can see
angels but he made it visible and now he
shows the mechanism he shows that at the
age of pushing the astronaut to earth
okay we understand the mechanism and he
used an object an angel do you believe
his theory well that's up to every
person
some people believe some people don't
that's a separate issue
now we're talking about belief in
existence what you believe exists out
there that's a separate matter
altogether
doesn't even enter the picture right now
we're only concerned about mechanisms
and the mechanism was clear the angel
carried the astronaut to earth now you
may say why does he go faster and faster
and faster why why does the astronaut
9.8 meters per second Square you can go
through a lot of stuff and criticize the
mechanism but you cannot criticize
existence you cannot criticize the
sumption of existence because that's the
way it's done in science for invisible
intangible untestable unhearable
unsellable eight entities you have to
make an assumption okay and no don't go
to the lab to try to prove if angels
exist because the guy is telling you
they're untouchable and unseeable so
you're not going to detect angels with
an experiment okay so so let's
understand the the scientific method
first because that's where people have
problems people think that scientific
method is about believing in existence
oh I don't believe in angels now it's
got nothing to do I don't care if you do
believe in angels or not doesn't matter
okay it has nothing to do it's
irrelevant your belief okay the guy
proposed of an object and he showed the
mechanism period we're done okay now
comes another religious person he's a
Protestant okay he's not a cat he's a
Protestant he says oh no it's God and he
makes an assumption so okay the other
guy made an assumption about angels I'm
gonna make an assumption about God I'm
gonna say that let us assume that God
exists okay and there you see what he
proposes well I got a problem here this
this time I do have a problem because
now God is doing something from action
at a distance I don't see what the cause
is from the finger to the astronaut I
don't see the mechanism all I see is
that the guy's pointing at the at the
astronaut in the ass around Falls to
earth I don't see what the mechanism is
do you and so the guy said well you
don't understand you see God is
omnipotent he he has superpowers well
yeah he now he makes that assumption he
says God is all-powerful he can do
anything he wants so how should I take
that well yeah then you bring Billy
oaken you know you bring Billy oakum you
say look you apply of Occam's rule you
say well the least assumptions and here
he's making a whopper of an assumption
so yeah I mean if you're gonna say that
God is all-powerful we don't need to
need a mechanism because that's what you
say
doesn't have a mechanism user says God
is all-powerful is that an explanation
for a mechanism no I don't see the
mechanism when the angel I saw the
mechanism I saw push so at least I
understood the mechanism proposed by the
angel theory but God theory I don't see
it I just see magic black magic and yeah
some people believe it okay couldn't
believe it I you know I'm just saying
how it works in in science okay that's
that's the point that I'm trying to make
here okay okay now we have a really
[ __ ] individual and he comes from
mathematical physics and he's gonna do
it not with God not with angels he
doesn't believe in all that nonsense no
he's going to introduce force he's not
gonna do it before us because forces of
physical objects oh yes force pushing on
the Astra he says that I do it what
force well now I have a big problem
because now we're not talking about an
angel pushy now we're saying there's a
concept he calls force and he's going to
push the astronaut with this concept and
he says no but forces a physical object
what do you mean some physical all I see
is a bunch of words there you know what
is for us can you draw it for me I want
to see a surface the surface push there
and I don't see that all I see a bunch
of letters pushing on a guy and this is
where we run into trouble with the
mathematical physicist because what they
want to do is use concepts of concepts I
mentioned earlier they wouldn't
introduce concepts and do physics with
concepts they want to push energy around
and and you know warp time and push the
force and draw the mass no such things
so you can't do physics you cannot
explain you cannot give a physical
interpretation to a mechanism using
concepts that's the issue
and here I mean let me show you now this
is the what you would have to present to
a mathematical physics it would present
something like this you would show them
say look here we have a seesaw okay why
does it go up and down I mean what is it
manually we have black magic there
or you present something else something
similar something another phenomenon
common phenomena here you have you know
a box that just goes up and you say how
does it do it I don't see anything I
can't touch anything it just goes up
it's by magic is he gonna put force in
there is that what you're gonna do is
he's gonna just put some kind of concept
in there's you gonna say love pulls on
the box
and here we have our famous fella felix
the cat and he's gonna wave his arm you
know dude say abracadabra okay gonna
wave it abracadabra and he breaks the
window did you see how it broke
try it again let's let's look at it one
more time okay so Felix waves his magic
wand you walk and breaks the window so
what broken a concept was it force well
let's see here we can see how Felix
broke the window according to
mathematical physics he did it with
force oh I see so he set the force
through the window a bunch of a
five-letter words really a four-letter
word but yeah okay so is that what broke
the the window force and so now you see
the problem now you see why we need
objects because you know we can't see
what happened here in any of those cases
we don't know how the seesaw went up
went up and down we don't know how the
box was lifted or pushed we don't know
how the window broke because they were
all invisible intent we look we can't
see what what happened and so what are
we gonna do this or are we just gonna
introduce some concepts and say well
here it was mass and over there it was
energy and then over there was force and
then a field came over and then charge
moved up and down is that what we're
gonna say is that how we're gonna
explain how these things happened we
don't do that because we can see every
object in our ordinary lives and yeah
when you go in there right you get these
situations where you you are able to
explain
because you see him and so you say okay
how did the seesaw go up and down well
here you see it okay there were two
fellows there you know going up and down
we can understand it you know because he
said okay it was these two guys that
were on the seesaw no wonder it was
moving we couldn't see them before and
with the box you can see the pulley now
say okay there was a rope that's what it
was we couldn't see the road so if the
Rope is invisible are you gonna put a
concept in there and say oh the box went
up because of a concept and Felix you
know yeah we can get an idea how that
thing broke out the window broke he had
a horseshoe total around him and then he
throws it now we can understand how the
window broke
was it magic do we need black magic to
explain this no of course not not
straightforward because now you saw the
object and that's what we got to do we
got to make the invisible visible and as
kid stuff it's kindergarten stuff but if
you use concepts such as mass and energy
and all these four-letter words that
they have in mathematical physics then
you're not going to understand anything
because they're using a concept to give
you a physical interpretation that's the
issue okay okay so uh there are other
people and in the in the cns and these
guys say no no it's the ether we do it
all with particles the quantum way
everything is done with particles well
again I got a problem here because I
don't understand the mechanism all I see
is a bunch of particles the guy is
falling why is the guy falling because
if the particles are everywhere and so
what these people have to do is say well
you know some particles are coming from
over here and not as many from over
there and then you try to find
mechanisms to try to explain that
difference okay well you know the
problem here is that we don't know what
this ether is and so I have to define it
for them you look it up
let me put myself back in here if if you
look it up you'll find this dictionary
eat a hypothetical substance substance
okay
supposed to occupy all space postulated
to account for the propagation of
electromagnetic radiation through space
you go to the Wikipedia in physics ether
theories also known as ether ether
theories okay
proposed the existence of a medium a
space filiz substance space filling it
fills space what could fill space
particles that's what they're thinking
they're not thinking that space is made
out of a single piece because no one
would be able to move no no ether is is
particles that's what it is and there's
a space-filling substance or field what
is field another concept so it's so
space is filled with concept it's filled
with love
that's what's gonna do the trick that's
what field is a bunch of numbers values
that's all it is that's what the word
field means values that's it
a field of you know it's a bunch of it's
a beehive of numbers of values thought
to be necessary is a transmission medium
for the propagation of electromagnetic
or gravitational forces how does Bill
get around it ether bunch of particles
that's what it that's what they're
saying
now saying that ether is a bunch of
particles the only issue is whether
space is filled with particles like your
space is a container that gets filled
with all these marbles or whether space
is the ether in which case space is made
of particles and if it's made of
particles you got to tell me what's in
in between each particle what delineates
what encapsulate each particle if I mean
if space is made out of particles are
other particles perfectly cubic so
they're surface the surface and even in
that case if we have cubic little
particles you gotta tell me what
separates one cubic particle from
another cubic particle even if they're
face-to-face because otherwise they're
just one particle if you have two
particles then there's something
separating them and you gotta identify
that something what is it what separates
particles of space so you got problem
either way either space is a container
that contains marbles or you have all
these particles in there let's make them
cubic to make it very simple for them
you have cubic particles face-to-face
what separates each qubit particle from
the other one that's why you got an
answer if you can answer that question
well you get a beer okay
and yeah we need rational answers not
some stupid thing okay now
the wrath of this he says oh I can tell
you how the astronaut comes down to
earth
and he says the lucky slides along
space-time that's what it is
there he goes it's a slide so he slides
down to earth right and so we got a
problem because space-time you know
they're saying that's time is warped
you're saying what do you mean time is
warp see if time is a is a physical is
not a physical object what's this
nonsense about time being warped okay so
you know they got a big problem there
and of course they say well you know
that's the physical and you're not
supposed to take the physical
interpretation literally you're not
supposed to think space-time literally
what does that mean that means you gave
us a presentation you said this is the
mechanism and then when we questioned
your your your logic to be nice with
them they say oh no but you were
supposed to take it literally of course
there's no such thing as space-time and
we cannot imagine space-time because
it's for it I mentioned I give you all
this runaround and you say well I just
wanted to know why the asteroid belt I
got explained that how did you ask
around make it to earth and they say
slides along space-time because there's
this depression the guy has no other
choice but to slide downwards into the
depression and you say well then
space-time is some kind of slide some
talk to Brogan you know and he said no
no you're not supposed to take it
literally so they're running around in
circles you know you'll never get a
straight answer from a relativist what
does the there's another group the
electric universe these deranged fellows
and they say no it's electricity okay
and so here we have this electricity and
the guys falling
yeah strands falling through electricity
okay and yeah we have a problem with
this obviously it's nonsense and you say
why well because at least two reasons
and you're the first ones they have no
definition of electricity you have the
electric do numbers they don't know what
electric means and here you have it okay
I've presented it in the past you can
look it up there electricity is a
fundamental quality of matters so it is
used to characterize other things thus
consensus opinion is
precision in other words we don't have a
definition guys like all bedrock
presumptions such as gravity or time
reducing electric terminology into
smaller units is impossible because it
lies at the bottom the lexical well in
other words we don't have a definition
guys but then they make some idiotic
statements like electricity which we
define as the flow travels so we have a
flow that travels okay and then they use
also words of being temptation they say
electromagnetic energy flows a concept
flows energy flows or they say
electricity moves through a DC Circuit
in the wires as particles of charge what
do you mean charge charge well they are
these are particles of love charge is a
concept charge is a concept in the
electric universe has never learned that
and of course when you confront them
they say oh you're playing semantics now
you're doing word wizardry bill no no it
just goes directly to there yeah I mean
you have to start with definitions the
other problem with the electric universe
why it's total nonsense is these people
are saying that all of space the entire
universe is full of particles okay so
what they're saying is that we have a
plasma out there everywhere so when you
go out it that when the astronaut goes
out into space he bounces against this
plasma that's just covering him every
smothering him this is absolute nonsense
you have ten to the minus eleven ten to
the minus twelve tore out there in space
on the moon in the what is in the solar
wind you cannot have a plasma with such
low vacuum hey and you know what can I
say and of course you don't have a plan
you don't have electricity so this
nonsense that the electric universe says
that all stars and all galaxies are
connected by filaments absolute nonsense
besty when they can't define to begin
with you know they can't define their
atom just just like we had with Britta
see here just show me your atom like
electric universe just has to start with
the atom show me a picture of your atom
I don't care the mother nature's atom
your atom when you're gonna use for
electricity what are you gonna use a
little bead going around the nucleus is
that your atom is that how you're going
to produce electricity charges going
from atom to atom is that your
irrational explanation for electricity
so now they have to start at the atom we
need to find what the atom looks like
before we can even listen to the
electric universe okay
and I like the last ones better because
we invited everybody to the sands and
one of the guys is from the Flat Earth
Society and of course they do at Flat
Earth like they have this astronauts
falling to look to Flat Earth okay so
yeah you can choose that one if you
think that's a better idea okay how do
rational folk do it yeah it is here we
have the rope model yeah you can take it
to the bank okay this is why an
astronaut falls to earth every atom in
his body is connected to every atom that
constitutes the earth okay and now you
can see why he falls at 9.8 meters per
second square in other words why he
accelerates towards the Earth when you
fall from an airplane without your
parachute you know you fall faster and
faster and faster and faster and that's
why because more and more ropes fan out
from every atom in your body that's
connected to every atom that constitutes
the earth so you can see a mechanism now
that you can understand a physical
mechanism and so you know the the people
in the a seance say well bill but I
don't believe in your O's they're just a
concept and I can't see them and touch
them I don't believe they exist
so you haven't explained the mechanism
well here's a rope all ropes in the
universe have shape therefore qualify as
an object just like the angel angel
qualifies an object this qualifies as an
object so we got the object part taken
care of every atom is connected to the
other atom to all other atoms that's an
assumption we make an assumption now
we're gonna explain the mechanism the
issue is not whether you believe that
ropes exist you could
that to your church we don't care if you
believe or not it has nothing to do with
what we're talking about we're talking
about mechanisms did you understand the
mechanism here it is again I just need
to know if you understood the mechanism
being proposed if every atom of the
astronaut is tied to every atom in the
earth we can explain why he accelerates
towards the earth okay that's what you
got to understand do you believe in it
we don't care if you do or not because
belief has to do with religion you can
have your own religion we don't care you
can have your own explanation you can
have a different religion doesn't matter
we just want you to understand the
mechanism that's what the seance was
about about mechanisms okay did you
understand the mechanism you understood
the mechanism we're done whether you
believe in it whether you believe that
ropes exist whether you in your tiny
mind believe that rope is not a physical
object well then you got a mental
problem you got to start by defining the
word object we need to know what you
mean by object and if you're gonna say
that the rope doesn't exist and be nice
if you would define the word exists as
well the two words we need to in order
to do physics okay so you got two issues
you got to define the word object and
you got to define the word exist or real
actuality being whatever you want to
call it does matter they're all synonyms
so two words object and exist just
define them and then you can start
criticizing until then you cannot even
begin and then the other issue is that
you know we're the sense this conference
whatever was about mechanisms if you
understood the mechanisms the conference
is over you can then go out there the
watercooler and talk about whether you
believe whether they exist or not that's
a separate issue right now we're only
concerned about the mechanism of do you
understand the mechanism we can't
understand the particle magic mechanism
because it doesn't make any sense
we can't understand what the Flat Earth
for sure we can't understand the
irrational electric universe mechanism
because it's totally [ __ ] aside from
the fact that they cannot you know
illustrate their atoms so they don't
have a starting point they don't know
what el electricity is they don't have a
definite
for it so they can't even start and for
sure you know we can't accept the god
one because it's uh from distance you
know God just waves his finger
you know that's black magic we can't
understand the angel the angel theory is
the best one there out of all so the
Catholic at least God got his thing in
there you say look at least I could
explain the mechanism I did with the
notch I did with an angel but quantum no
chance and general relativity no chance
electric universe no chance and flat
earthers are just about at the same
levels all of that they're on the same
boat with that we'll see you what is it
on Sunday and hopefully we get back to
Aristotle and and Euclid we'll see you
then on Sunday